foreign
what if I need it later oh what if I
need it later so many people have sent
me this video
um
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'm so mad we didn't make that
that's so good
so what he's bringing up here is the
Justin Case fallacy
I'm gonna hold on to this just in case
because what if I need it but what I
love here and this is an exercise we've
done with a lot of listeners and
especially at our live events as soon as
you say it out loud you see how absurd
it is
I'm going to hold on to this toga
because what if I need it what if I want
to be Julius Caesar
of course as soon as I said out loud I
feel compelled to let go of the thing
and that is the exercise that has helped
me so many times
I will be incomplete without this shirt
as soon as I say that I let go of the
shirt I will not be Joshua Fields
Milburn without these jeans
I won't be respected if I don't own
these shoes or this belt or this car no
one will like me if I don't own the
things that I own and as soon as I say
that out loud
it's like the universe gives me
permission to let go yeah you know one
antidote to what if I need it is what if
I don't
because if the answer to what if I need
it turns out to be yes at least I have
the possibility of getting the thing
back but if the answer to what if I need
it turns out to be no I don't have the
possibility of getting the time back the
time that I wasted holding on to
something that I never actually needed
the time I spent being held back from
the life I could have been free to live
because of this hypothetical question
that haunted me and convinced me that I
needed to carry around around a weight
that I never actually needed what if I
need it what if you don't hmm that's
great man the just in case items or the
what if I needed items for me is it's
been so easy to let go of because well
hey the whole just in case rule in our
experience with coming up with that rule
but also you can't prepare for
everything and like if you try to
prepare for everything then
in a way like you're prepared for
nothing yes did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free